alex est alors bonjour bonjour je suis
journaliste européen j'y tiens
journalistes européens c'est rectifié
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
en tout cas ce matin sur rtl france
alors on le disait boris johnson
envisage de réquisitionner l'armée pour
acheminer les sens vers les stations
service et faire face ainsi au manque de
chauffeurs alors un manque de chauffeurs
on le dit lié à la pandémie on parle
aussi du bric site ce que réfute le
gouvernement alors à quoi précisément ce
manque de chauffeurs et du
c'est clair et net
moi je suis à paris j'habite dans
l'union européenne et c'est vrai qu'il
ya un manque de chauffeurs routiers mais
pour le moment il n'y a pas de manque ni
de pétrole ni de bien dans les rayons
des supermarchés en grande bretagne nous
avons eu la pandémie également dans
l'union européenne mais a passé ses
manques dans les stations service ni les
supermarchés donc le break site et
jouent clairement l'europe réponde le
problème en grande bretagne c'est que
vous venez de le voir avec john justice
le ministre de l'agriculture qui nie pas
ce que le paul johnson s'est entouré
dans un cabinet de bréxent eater qui nie
que le break sidki savoie le moindre
rôle à jouer là-dedans vous avez une
presse à 80 % qui appuient le pack site
qui dit de briques si tu n'y es pour
rien mais le problème c'est que il
n'explique pas le lecteur ni à leurs
électeurs comment il se fait que qu'en
europe même avec un manque de chauffeurs
signé depuis ce problème assez
clairement dit au président ce pays a
passé cinq ans à dire un des chauffeurs
routiers de l'est de l'europe on veut
plus de vous chez nous chez nous rentrer
chez vous maintenant il s'étonne que les
gens ne se précipite pas pour répondre à
l'appel pour venir comme en trois mois
seulement pour avoir des visas
provisoires c'est un problème clairement
lié aux briques site et pourquoi un
problème qui a lieu en ce moment
maintenant ça fait une semaine à tout nu
ce que les britanniques se ruent vers
les stations-service comment est-ce
qu'elle a démarré cette crise très
précisément
dans les supermarchés deux mois à peu
près ont commencé à remarquer qu'ils
n'avaient pas assez de chauffeurs
routiers quand vous avez d un manque de
chauffeurs routiers en europe ce qui est
le cas je ne dis pas mais vous avez 27
et plus pays dans le marché unique où
les camionneurs et les marchandises
circulent librement la grande bretagne a
mis des contrôles à ses frontières
ce qui fait que c'est beaucoup plus
difficile passé la douane et c'est
beaucoup de plus difficile d'avoir le
droit de travailler en grande bretagne
avec en plus comme l'a dit olaf schulze
hier ont répondu à une question de l'un
de mes collègues il a dit en plus ici en
europe on paie mieux maintenant nos
chauffeurs routiers donc il ya vraiment
très peu de motivation je suis allé sur
le site du journal roumain adevarul pour
voir quelle était l'accueil de l'offre
de portions de proposer des visas
temporaires à des roumains venez chez
nous s'il vous plaît on vous a dit qu'on
veut plus de vous mais si vous pouvez
revenir juste trois mois pour nous aider
de moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que
cette proposition a été fraîchement
accueillie il suffit de mettre dans
google transit jeunes et puis c'est pas
très sympathique les avis des
britanniques parce que ils ont fait une
mauvaise expérience là-bas qui veulent
pas y retourner en tout cas l'armée elle
est prête à intervenir pour acheminer
cette essence est ce que ça pourrait
suffire finalement est ce que le royaume
uni a vraiment besoin d'eux d'autres
chauffeurs routiers est ce qu'il
pourrait s'en tirer avec l'armé
visiblement ainsi ça a été confirmée
donc hier soir que paul johnson a mis
l'armée à disposition mais écoutez cc
c'est pas très sérieux je veux bien que
les gens qui sont dans l'armée sont des
gens sérieux mais j'ai écouté une
interview à la bbc pas plus tard qu'hier
ou à un chauffeur de camion était placé
très sympa mais quand même un soldat
vous ne mettiez au volant un énorme
camion avec du combustible
inflammable derrière il faut qu'ils
aient un entraînement - il m'a fallu six
mois pour savoir quand à manoeuvrer ces
camions donc certes c'est une solution
d'urgence ça va peut-être rassurer les
gens mais c'est pas une solution à long
terme le problème c'est qu'il n'ya pas
assez de chauffeurs de camionneurs en
grande bretagne ils ont tout fait pour
faire fuir les gens qui étaient prêts à
venir quand il était dans le marché
unique qui pouvait circuler librement
pour le faire maintenant il faut qu'ils
gèrent cette conséquence qui est
clairement dû aux breaks site c'est tout
le royaume uni qui est touchée
aujourd'hui non évidemment et puis il ya
beaucoup de gens qui paniquent en ce
moment il ya ainsi de combustible c'est
juste qu'il n'y a pas assez de
chauffeurs pour le véhicule et mais il
n'ya pas que ça par exemple d'enlever
les maisons de retraite a beaucoup de
travailleurs dans les maisons de
retraite britanniques étaient d'origine
européenne ils sont repartis chez eux
quand vous dites pendant cinq ans comme
j'ai dit aux migrants comme on les
appelle maintenant grand beau talent
européenne veut plus vous chez nous faut
pas s'étonner après si tous ces gens
partent les hôtels les restaurants les
maisons de retraite et les camionneurs
qui a beaucoup de manquements de
personnel et c'est clairement c'est pas
le qu'ovide jeu tout le monde a eu du
coc vide on n'a pas ça en europe ils ont
aussi des problèmes là en grand mot
thann c'est le break site il n'ya pas
aussi c'est ce phénomène de panique on a
vu ces images des files d'attentes
interminables devant les stations
service les britanniques ont peur et
finalement est bien est ce que ça ne
crée pas là encore une pénurie
évidemment c'est comme on l'a vu avec le
co vide avec le papier toilette c'est le
même phénomène il ya un problème de
panique c'est sûr mais un problème de
panique il n'y a pas de fumée sans feu
parce que y manque ces camionneurs y
manque des travailleurs dans tous les
secteurs
la population britannique vit un peu il
avait une manne de main d'oeuvre pas
chère lors de leurs
quand il était membre de l'union
européenne qui était ok pour venir pour
travailler en grande bretagne maintenant
la libre circulation c'est fini ils ont
trouvé des jobs mieux payés où il était
beaucoup mieux accueillis dans d'autres
pays de l'union européenne ils vont
parvenir c'est ça le problème du bauxite
vous pouvez pas à fonder votre économise
sur 22 la main d'oeuvre étrangère pas
cher dire à cette main d'oeuvre on veut
plus de vous chez nous et puis vous
plaindre après quand vous n'avez plus de
main-d'oeuvre étrangère pas cher en tout
cas un mot pour conclure on a pu voir
notamment sur les réseaux sociaux les
britanniques prendre la situation
finalement avec humour c'est le flegme
britannique
c'est un cliché moi je suis beaucoup sur
twitter je suis fou de compte ce
britannique s'est pas trouvé ton divorce
a insulté les chansons carrément furieux
il ya des infirmières qui arrive pas à
remplir leur leur voiture pour aller
travailler l'économie dépend du fait que
les gens puissent circuler je veux dire
c'est quand même grave si en grande
bretagne contrairement encore une fois
ce qui se passe dans le reste de l'union
européenne si on qu'on fasse appel à
l'armée je trouve que c'est quand même
assez
assez comme je vois pas trop gelé en
fait on dit toujours les britanniques
prennent savez avec du shape je vous
venez de regarder le même reportage tout
ça et tourner et vous même s'il ya pas
beaucoup de flegme et moi je le vois pas
non plus je regarde beaucoup les terry
britannique je ne vois pas beaucoup ce
flegme les gens sont furieux on a pu le
voir un peu notamment sur les réseaux
sociaux tout de même en tout cas merci à
vous alex taylor d'avoir répondu à nos
questions ce matin sur rtl france je le
rappelle vous êtes journalistes
européens